hello i'm jordan mendoza having the best
time of my life at cluster fest since
this is a Comedy Festival I'm asking
comedy fans for their help deciding
whether my Twitter drafts are a perfect
joke or total trash unsalvageable
this one's really good somehow got
rejected by Colgate University and
Listerine College haven't heard back yet
from Sonicare State or Harvard all right
that's a terrible joke I mean I love dad
jokes that's awful
say it funny you're next time are you
guys comedians No
so just they're not comedians so just
keep that in mind I love dull shampoo
but I hate thinking about how many doves
they kill to make it that's why I'm
switching the Aussie shampoo because
there are too many Australians around
it's an island of criminals hey that's a
fantastic joke sir genocide is hilarious
this one's a song and the situation is
Flo Rida has a house guest welcome to my
house make yourself at home now me casa
su casa please take off your shoes it
was a bad joke but I could tell that you
put timing of the song so people always
say the haters but I'm personally
exhausted from all this intercourse a
lot of people just like me that was
immediately funny immediately funny New
York Times thinking about starting a
ground grape groundbreaking female rap
group in Tibet I'm calling it Himalayan
salt and pepper all right well if you
guys didn't like that one you're gonna
love this one
pitching an animated Nick jr. series
about a groundbreaking female rap group
into bed I'm calling it Himalayan salt
and pepper pig hey an improve
okay it grosses me out when people say
mother I would never my mom she's not
even that hot my sister is really cute
though as a mother I'm gonna say no you
guys are sisters I do think your sisters
really cute I don't have a sister you
know this is that Cinnabon okay
I'd like a synonym roll you mean a
cinnamon roll kinda it's a different
roll but it means the same thing Just My
Luck
I won the lottery again so the joke is
like he's like Oh Just My Luck like
something bad happened but then he won
the lottery so like why would you be
upset about that and it's clearly
happened to him a few times
I like the explanation of the dough it
made it better crazy to think that when
I send my buds text messages I'm
literally sending good vibrations unless
their phone is on a vibrate or I'm mad
at them or something
all right you left you have to throw it
up
what the